all right let's get to the mailbag for
the week you can write info at
davidpackman.com if you have something
to say a question a comment a complaint
a demand for an apology or a retraction
which are very very frequent on the
program sometimes we'll also highlight a
YouTube comment or a Twitter message or
something else I do want to you know I
keep getting the question uh David are
you getting hit with more anti-semitism
since the Kanye Nick Fuentes stuff has
sort of been mainstreamed I get a lot of
anti-Semitism anyway but it's definitely
higher and more frequent and people just
seem more willing to say certain things
here's just like one example Paul wrote
on YouTube David pakman Shameless Jew
who often has a hard on that he is proud
of this idea of a Shameless Jew
is uh you know it's not like you're
using the k word but this is actually a
pretty gross thing which is the idea
that you should be ashamed if you are a
Jew as Paul says here
and a lot of these ideas are very
pervasive among the anti-semitic right
you should be ashamed
you should have [ __ ] you shouldn't leave
your house you shouldn't have a YouTube
channel certainly you should be hiding
your face and hiding out in general uh
but yes significant amounts of
anti-Semitism uh since and I believe as
a result of as a result of the
normalization of such anti-Semitism due
to some pretty prominent people
including Kanye next message is from Lu
app also coming to us from YouTube luapp
says Pac-Man you are a Kami why do you
not move to China well
I'm not a communist
I don't speak any Chinese dialect
I don't know anybody in China
and I have no interest in moving to
China why are you trying to change
America to a communist system I'm not
I'm not a communist just move Maga will
never let this country change without a
now these are capitalized just like
Trump does major dust up prepare
yourself it is coming now of course this
is an allusion to violence it's
important to understand when folks say
we're going to do a lot
prevent this country from becoming
communist they're talking about violence
you know they're not talking about
signing a petition they're not talking
about a letter writing campaign they're
talking about violence often involving
firearms and uh now at the same time the
U.S isn't actually about to become
Communists so I don't really know that
anything's going to happen because
that's not going on let's go next from
YouTube over to Facebook Facebook where
Greg wrote in and said you are the
biggest hypocrite on everything
Democrats are taking the law and order
form this great country people like you
are the problem typical Democrat now
we've talked about the law and order
stuff a bunch now
the right loves to say
we are for free speech we never want to
censor or limit speech
until they do and then you go on Truth
social and you see that you're not
allowed to post about the January 6th
Insurrection depending on what you post
and on and on and on they're for speech
but not really well they are certainly
against regulating businesses right
businesses must be allowed to do
whatever they want all the time we're
against regulating businesses oh but no
but
social media social media platforms
though should be forced to publish our
right wing messages social media
platforms should be regulated to be
forced to publish our covid
disinformation but we're against
regulating businesses and then of course
we get to we're for Law and Order well
on January 6th hundreds of your people
committed all sorts of different crimes
in Washington DC and now your concern
isn't let's make sure we prosecute
lawbreakers it's they're being treated
unfairly they shouldn't be held in
pre-trial detention and on and on and on
all of these are just talking points
they don't mean any of it they're not
really the party of Law and Order Jordan
Roden and said are you a FN idiot
and then they said here's a suggestion
go get your brain checked out you
democrat loving loser this will be the
last one of this style and then we'll
get get on to more substance and stuff
the reason I highlight this one
continues to be
I'm not a Democrat
I don't care about the Democratic party
I see the Democratic party essentially
as a corporation
whose primary objective is its own
self-preservation and
self-aggrandizement I see it as having
worthier political goals than the
Republican party yes but I'm not a
Democrat and quite frankly I don't care
about the Democratic party and yet I
regularly get messages like this which
by the way conflict with you're a
communist the actual Communists hate the
Democratic Party
they see it as almost indistinguishable
from the Republican party and a tool of
all the same special interests so am I a
communist a group that hates the
Democratic party or am I a Democrat I'm
actually neither I am an unaffiliated
when it comes to political party
Social Democrat that's what I am it's
very very simple okay next message is
from grant grant brings up a great
question about LGBT community title and
says hello David I've noticed you've
recently started using the term lgbtq
instead of LGBT to refer to the
community I'm curious what inspired you
to make the adjustment should this be a
change that all of us in the Progressive
Movement adopt or is it simply a
personal preference I'm happy to make a
correction in my speech if necessary
hope you and your loved ones have fully
recovered from covid thanks for your
hard work and excellent content you know
I didn't even know I don't I'm not in my
mind I still say LGBT
but I guess it is true I've used lgbtq
to some degree recently I think part of
it may be if I'm reading an article if
we're using as a source an article that
says lgbtq I will say lgbtq I know I I
believe the Q means queer which I think
is more of a it's a vague term it's not
oh well I'm I'm a lesbian okay so okay
you're a woman attracted to other women
I think Q is queer and it's a more
general term I'm glad to include it in
my mind I use the term LGBT I think
everybody knows what community I'm
talking about and and certainly I uh
whichever term I'm using I'm not trying
to exclude anyone that's that's for sure
um okay here Divergent views among my
audience about the Brittany Greiner
situation many of you do not think that
she should have been brought home in
this prisoner swap here's someone uh
Mike who wrote in about the clown show
and says David Brittany Greiner should
be compelled to finish her incarceration
in an American prison now that she's
been released from Russian custody
thanks to President Biden what a clown
show
let's all feel sorry for a jock who
deliberately flaunted Russian law I
think you mean flouted actually clouded
Russian law got caught tried in a
Russian Court sentenced only to be
released because of President Biden's
negotiations what a effing's joke
short and pithy enough well it doesn't
really make sense that she finished her
sentence in the U.S because
what she did in the U.S what she did is
differently criminalized than in Russia
so it doesn't really make sense it's
it's sort of like saying oh someone was
gay in another country that criminalizes
being gay we got them out but now they
should finish their sentence in the U.S
well the in the U.S Being gays in a
crime so that doesn't really make any
sense now I do understand people having
The View
that this was the wrong intervention for
Joe Biden to make that it's actually
Paul Whelan who should have been freed
Etc but uh serve the rest of her
sentence here that doesn't make any
sense part of why the U.S intervened was
because the the sentence was deemed to
be unfairly harsh
okay Spencer wrote in about religion
and says hi David do you think Jews are
better people than Christians oh come on
guys I don't think they commit very many
crimes in the USA and I've never heard
of a Jewish terrorist I'm sure much of
the hate in the USA is from Christians
whereas Jews are more tolerant people so
first of all I'm against the idea of
better people so no I don't think Jews
are better people than Christians I
think all people are as gr we might see
individuals who do immoral things which
we criticize but uh the idea of groups
of people that are better this is this
is not the way I think about things so
so I would not uh no that it's a no from
me
um inter
let's just leave it there it's an
interesting message but what I'm not
sure what else to say about Jay Fran
made a YouTube comment
and says well said David as a Jew this
oh sorry this is about the Kanye
anti-Semitism okay J front says well
said David as a Jew this at first was
Goofy but has quickly become extremely
disturbing and honestly frightening
having Kanye as a massive cultural
figure and influence in society I see
many people now repeating Kanye's
rhetoric and I'm very worried this will
just continue to escalate yeah you know
there's a lot of people who are arguing
and sometimes they'll write in who cares
what a musical artist and designer
clothing designer Kanye says about
um uh Jews just don't pay any attention
just ignore him that's it just ignore
him uh but the unfortunate reality is
not only does Kanye have a very large
megaphone
not because of the coverage of his
anti-Semitism but because of his own
megaphone but also a lot of the people
that are hearing his message about Jews
are people who are a much blank or slate
folks that listen to like my show for
example are probably aware of the
history of anti-Semitism and they've
sort of been inoculated to it because
they already understand a lot of these
talking points and and anti-Semitism
imagine that you aren't familiar with
that history and suddenly Kanye a
musical artist you admire or maybe a
clothing designer you really like the
pants that he designed or something like
that or the boots I don't know you don't
really have uh any protection against
this disinformation and Kanye's saying
the Jews are controlling this and
they're conspiring to control that and
they did this bad thing to me and a
Jewish doctor tried to get me killed by
giving me medication all this stuff that
starts to become your worldview so I
actually do think it is very important
very important to take it head on and to
do everything we can to prevent Kanye
from becoming the authority on Jews in
the minds of many of these people that's
my view I think jfron is saying
something very similar we have such a
great bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com get instant
access and we will see you then with the
coupon code 24 starts now
because it did 24 is off and running we
will see you then